i'm josh fullen
and i've been making independent film
for over a decade now
uh mostly in new york as of seven months
ago in la
and we just recently on thanksgiving
released
my ninth produced
fourth written third directed second
edited feature
love is dead starring alice kremelberg
al thompson lolita foster we did that in
self-distribution
fashion and self-distribution is a
somewhat fluid term
with a lot of definitions and meanings
uh at least right now
and this is our r
these are the five things that film
courage thinks
i should share with you about the at
least initial stages of that
self-distribution experience
and this is my fireplace the first thing
i would touch on about self-distribution
is the decision to do it uh it's not the
easiest way
to get your phil into the world uh it's
a great deal of work
so it's not for everyone in our case the
reason we chose to do it
was a range of things but one it was
hard to attract
interest in it from uh the companies
that you really want to be working with
uh or many of the companies that you
really want to be working with in the
distribution realm
um we had you know an extremely
difficult to sell subject matter
your son was raped he was what
you know most sales companies are not
looking to blaze new trails with the
material they acquire they want
something that's
just like a thing they know can sell but
maybe just a little bit different to
differentiated in the marketplace and
that
you know it's definitely not what we
made you beat your wife you touch your
daughters yet you were here quoting the
bible
like you're not a horrible book and on
top of the subject matter we
the actual aesthetic of the film is
weird we shot the film to look like this
1970s or 80s uh television sitcom so
it's shot in a four by three aspect
ratio
we degraded the 4k image to make it look
standard
definition and look like it's playing
off this shitty vhs tape um
there's commercial breaks an opening
title sequence there's just
a range of things that make it not look
like anything
that really is out there in my opinion
which i consider that to be an asset but
sales companies
are a little more hesitant with
something like that so it was difficult
to get a partner that we really liked
uh we did get interest from smaller
companies that um
you know some not so bad some bad and
uh the reason you know
a smaller company like that in my
experience after having done this for a
decade isn't going to do anything
they're not going to bring any added
value to the project they're going to
throw it on the platforms which
chimpanzee could do uh in this day and
age
and uh you know they're not gonna put
any marketing behind it they're not
gonna do anything special
so why give them in most cases you're
you're gonna have to give away like 30
percent
of your revenue off the gross minus
expenses that they're going to deduct
from going to film markets and where
they may or may not be really doing
anything for your film
um so we didn't want to give away that
much
for that little so we decided or i
decided maybe
initially and got shawnee my co-producer
to
to agree to it uh to just do it
ourselves
and and uh i have self-distributed
before so i thought this time around
um that i could perhaps
do it for little to no money which is
what we had left over from our 32 and a
half thousand dollar budget
and you know there are some sacrifices
we had to make um
and i would direct you to uh the article
i wrote for film courage that
led to me uh having to make this video
reading that you can decide whether all
this work and the
potential payoff for it is for you but
for us
it made the most sense the second thing
about self-distribution
uh for zero dollars in particular that i
would uh touch on
is the assets required and in turn the
skills i think you need to have or have
cheap uh to free access to
in order to accomplish this um one of
the things you're going to need
especially in a marketplace where
everyone's just you know blowing through
a million different titles and whatever
platform they watch their content on
is some really good key art that
captures what the film's about and
uh is compelling in one way or another
and uh
you know sets you somehow apart from the
other things that they could be picking
uh and in our case with our key art for
love is dead um
we you know you first of all you got
any producing 101 you need to have an
onset photographer that's taking
pictures
uh however you you know whether you're
paying them or
begging for favors out of photographers
or however you get it you need to have
the
actual imagery in order to create key
art with
in our case this picture was captured by
our
key and only pa and associate producer
slash art department assistant
slash a million other things utility
infield or josh goldsmith so that's
where we got the image from
and then i tinkered around with uh in
photoshop with it to get it to
this and then for actual delivery you're
gonna need to reformat it and do a
million different aspect ratios for the
aggregators and
and platforms all require different
specs on that so you need to have some
photoshop acumen
uh you also need some editing acumen i
think i think you know
editing the film and the trailer both in
this case for marketing materials the
trailer but
i think in order to achieve low budget
slash micro budget filmmaking in general
uh a director or writer director also
needs to be able to edit their stuff
because if you're outsourcing that
uh it's either gonna cost you money or
you're gonna be inconveniencing the [ __ ]
out of whoever you're begging for the
favors out of because it's a long
arduous pro
process to edit so for the purposes of
marketing materials editing the trailer
and being able to deliver that
and again multiple formats uh uh
for whatever platforms or aggregators
are requiring it uh is also a skill you
need to have
you'll also need captions a caption file
for pretty much all platforms these days
require that
closed captions and uh
you can either we paid for it it's one
of the few things we did spend money on
because
i have done it for the batteries not
included this amazon doc series i
i uh created direct edit
and uh also for all guys creatures my
very first
uh written produced feature and the
captioning euro the captioning stuff is
just the worst
job and most painstakingly
boring and worst job in the universe in
my opinion so
my heart goes out to the people at
rev.com who i usually
outsource this too they do it for a
dollar a minute so that's one area i
would recommend
even if it's only out of your pocket uh
to spend a few bucks
but um you will need to deliver that one
way or another and you can google of
course how to
the format you need for the srt delivery
syntax slash
whatever format so the third thing about
self-distributing love is dead
for zero dollars or relatively anyways
that i would touch on
is who we partnered with to do it there
are quite a few options out there these
days
uh for aggregating and getting on
uh you know the various platforms some
of which you can do yourself some you
can't
uh and that's you know not really for a
video where i'm talking to your face you
can google all that
and find out for yourself but the
companies
companies plural that we chose to work
with and i've worked with a bunch of
times for
for library titles this is the first
time i'm releasing initially with them
but film filmhub which is just
filmhub.com
uh and uh a partner of theirs that i've
also worked with separately
bidslate which is also just bidslate.com
and they're both companies that
do uh service a number of platforms
film hub 100 well over 100 worldwide
and they charge no fees up front
whatsoever
and they do take a cut on the back end
uh both of them i'm pretty sure are 80
20 uh so they take 20
uh off gross revenue received via
um platforms with them but they're not
exclusive so you can you know if you
want to do
certain platforms certain territories
whatever you can
cut those off and and figure those out
yourself and
just work with with bit slater film hub
uh
on whatever specific things you want to
work with them on so
that non-exclusive thing is very
attractive to me and obviously no cost
up front for the purposes of zero dollar
self-distribution is very attractive as
well
and i would highly recommend looking
into both of them the fourth thing
i would get into is marketing and uh
this is probably the area
that uh is most differentiated uh
between
self-distribution and working with a
distributor
um you know the only way
eyeballs are or are not getting on your
film uh
and actually generating revenue is
uh by way of your own work and spreading
the word and getting people to realize
that your film even exists
um and you know every there's a million
options with this
and i i couldn't begin to list them all
here either in the article i wrote for
film courage
or in this video uh but i can touch on a
few of the things that i
am doing for love is dead and will
continue to do and
have done for many of if not all my past
projects as well
um one of the things is
uh hometown press you know if you're
from a small town assuming you're not
from a big you know
major metropolis i'm from oberlin ohio
and
uh oberlin ohio being a city or a town
of 2000 people
when the college is not in session 10
000 when it is uh
there haven't been a whole lot of
filmmakers to come out of there so
um it's that is certainly a marketplace
uh
that you want to hit because these are
people that have known you all your life
and at least probably hopefully find it
somewhat cool that someone from
ohio is out doing this with their life
so um
you know i always reach back and talk to
the local radio station the local
newspaper surrounding newspapers uh you
might even be able to
weasel your way on to a local news
television uh program
so you know reaching out at least trying
to to to generate that interest
both because it should be easier for you
to
attract the attention of and because uh
it's also just a marketplace a
demographic
people that have known you forever and
uh hopefully like you at least a little
are potential sales so that's one thing
um the independent blog and filmmaking
uh podcast and blogging community
are other places you can reach out to
there's a million filmmaker
you know film courage is an example of
one of course but there are many others
uh that you can reach out to and uh you
know they're always looking podcast
hosts are always looking for new guests
people who are actually
making things happen making films so
don't be
afraid to reach out and try to tell your
story with and via them as well
there's also you know reddit is probably
one of the bigger
best examples of it but there are
there are other ways to contribute to
the independent filmmaking conversation
or just the film enthusiast and general
conversation the red is fantastic
because it you know it
subdivides these demographics into
individual
uh communities where the conversations
are happening that you can
participate in you got to be careful you
can't just go in there and
just shamelessly self-promote you have
to be
an actual uh live human being and
participate in the conversation
uh to bring added value to it not just
saying hey watch my my stupid [ __ ]
um so you know that but if you are
adding value to the conversation
you certainly can uh still talk about
your projects and and use them as
examples and
and that be a benefit to to the people
that you're you're
sharing that stuff with and they also
have the ama thing
which is you know they ask me anything
uh option which i usually do
with projects sometimes it's more
well-received than others but
uh you know you you did something very
hard you made a feature film
and not everyone has achieved that and
the people who are trying to and want to
achieve that
are i know i was
just endlessly looking for easier ways
tips tricks whatever just trying to find
help to get them to a place where they
can uh even begin but let alone finish
the process of making a
their own feature film so um sharing
your experience
uh is one way to again share your
projects
the fifth and final thing i would get
into uh about self distribution
particularly for zero dollars uh is the
understanding
that uh the problem never goes away and
this kind of
uh goes back to the first point about
whether
self-distribution is right for you but
you do need to have an understanding
going into
it that uh the you will always
have to be the one working to monetize
this film at least if you're doing your
job
uh and keeping your promise to your
investors that you're you know going to
try to maximize the revenue the film
generates uh
and you know there are projects
even where we had to distribute all guys
creatures we got a distributor
in the initial stages and uh you know we
still
had to both help them roll the film out
and we have since gotten all rights back
and i am now
uh or we are now um on a daily basis
trying to find ways to monetize
uh that film and and uh love is dead we
absolutely be doing that in ongoing
capacity too so
just an understanding that you know you
need to be working or to be doing your
job anyways
these every day you're working to find
new ways
uh and especially the digital
distribution landscape there's
you know new platforms popping up every
day and new ways to to achieve
monetization so
um you know the uh if
this is most applicable i think in the
sense that you know a lot of filmmakers
want to be making films and not
distributing films
so i think an understanding that
today's modern filmmaker independent
filmmaker is
also at least a little bit of a
distributor too
and you need to accept that and embrace
it i think
to really be successful doing stuff or
doing this stuff rather so
those are my five things i would want to
convey
uh about self-distributing and
i recommend you again read the full
article
that i wrote on this topic for film
courage and uh
check out both love is dead it's on
amazon uh
now and vimeo on demand and
uh the rest of my [ __ ] at nyeh
entertainment.com
and thanks for watching me ramble for
however long you watch this